this morning we focus on country music
singer and songwriter amanda shires you
might know her from the all female super
group the high women she also won a
grammy playing fiddle in her husband
jason isbell's band the 400 unit well
with her latest solo album take it like
a man the 40 year old performer is
stepping back into the spotlight shire
told our anthony mason she isn't holding
anything back
i was
[Music]
amanda shires made much of her new music
in silverneck studios on her nashville
farm
but she has another name for it actually
it's the barn of internal laundry the
barn of internal wandering
it's what's inside your mind
[Music]
it's where she writes and records
[Music]
where she paints and creates
under the dancing light of disco balls
it keeps you young i think disco balls
this is inspirational
shires was 10 when she took up the
fiddle in texas you spotted a fiddle in
a thrift shop a pawn shop had you played
the fiddle no
so why'd you want it i don't know it was
just it looked like it
that was what i was supposed to be doing
her dad bought it for her her mom paid
for lessons
by age 15 she was performing with the
renowned texas playboys
so did they have any hesitation about
inviting a 14 15 year old to play with
them
no i mean it helped them they're like 70
and 80. i could carry stuff
but shires had dreams of being a
songwriter i was known as a side person
and player in
texas it was 2004 when she hit the road
you came here to basically reinvent
yourself yes
and she did her new album take it like a
man is her seventh solo record
[Music]
she also performs with the 400 unit the
band of her husband jason ism
and it was shire's idea to create a
female country super group
[Music]
the high women also features brandy
carlisle maren morris and natalie hamby
what made you want to put together
that band
honestly it was my daughter made me want
to do it hello today we're doing spring
stinks she thought of mercy now six
while listening to a country radio
station that played 22 straight songs by
men then i called that station i said
hey i'd like to hear a little like a
song you know where a girl sings
[Music]
the high women's debut album hit number
one on the country chart in 2019. so the
songs come out of this
that no
lines come out of this
shires takes lyrics from her journals
and for her new album she says she went
deep down a well
what'd you find
myself
had that been missing
nope
timeout
you're right yeah
but she needed a moment
no worries
and when shires returned she talked
about her disappointment with people in
the music business
and then you get into a room with
somebody that says i don't think that's
a good song or i don't understand what
you're trying to do here yeah and it
starts to make anything that something's
wrong with you
yeah
did you take it personally
i mean obviously
[Music]
that influenced her new music so did
some troubles in her marriage so what
was going on
there was a disconnect
it began while isbell was recording his
album reunions in 2019. it was just a
war in the studio it was like a war he
was having with himself and with me
suddenly within our house he lived in
his own
invisible house and there was no windows
and no doors you couldn't even get to
him like he was there but he was
just impenetrable
[Music]
so
did you get into the house ultimately or
what happened oh yeah and you know you
would think you would get in it by
writing your confessional songs like um
fault lines and texting it to them
[Music]
i was gonna take that one off the record
and he said you gotta leave that one on
there it's true and it's a good song
[Music]
you moved out at one point for like 10
days
well during reunions hell yeah he had to
do some
of his own internal wandering
there's some
old wounds and things and stuff that he
had to get to a place he was ready to
get to
did he get there
yeah yeah he did but you feel like
you're in a better place
yeah i think
we're in a good place
and we're happy i think we're both still
in love
[Music]
isabel plays behind shires on much of
the new album
i'd like to say i'm really happy with
myself for crying at you
what is that feeling of satisfaction
that you feel the first person i got to
cry it wasn't you
and it's the only time it's going to
happen
i gave you that exclusive cry
[Music]
and anthony is here with us wow anthony
i was already a huge fan of andershires
and the high women but this interview
yeah there is so much going on there i
love how vulnerable she is in speaking
to you
but also you can tell
still waters run deep yeah a lot and i
want to say that first that producer
lawrence rothman helped her craft the
really striking sound on this album but
part of the reason she got tearful in
the middle of that conversation was she
said you know i almost gave up music i
thought music was breaking my heart but
then i realized it was people who were
breaking my heart and and i was really
upset that i even considered giving up
music and she i mean she went through
even more that i mean she had an ectopic
pregnancy
uh almost a year ago right after she was
in austin city limits uh she actually
like couldn't get out of bed one morning
she was in so much pain those are really
dangerous that's when a fertilized egg
develops outside the womb she's fine now
but that's just another thing that
amanda went through in the past year or
so anthony you do an amazing job but
this is one of my favorite sit-downs um
because as a married man
i identified with certain things she was
saying yeah she was very vulnerable
transparent and honest saying i had to
do some soul-searching yeah but so did
he yeah i think that's an important
lesson for all of us when you're in any
type of relationship it's okay to step
away for a second say i need to fix
myself and maybe you do too and when we
get back together we can get on the same
page and be evenly yoked they have a
very unusual artistic relationship you
could tell by what jason said put that
song on the album it you know it doesn't
reflect well on me but it's a great song
and it's true that tells you they back
each other up artistically and they did
that even through all of their troubles
i think a lot of people will take a
listen i mean if they didn't know who
she was already to see that type of
depth you want to know more you want to
hear those songs yeah it's real well
done once again awesome anthony thank
you